okay so getting into female war what
this does is this wraps up the trilogy
known as earth war for those of you who
don't know where who are just now
joining us in the in the hole aliens
comic thing
this comic are really the earth war line
of stories so basically a earth hive
nightmare asylum and this particular
video female war these took place before
alien 3 now the reason why that matters
is because of the fact that at the end
of aliens all we knew about Hicks and
Newt and Ripley was that they had gotten
into those cryo pods on the Sulaco and
they had presumably went back to earth
and that was it that's that's all we had
it was just open-ended after that and so
what these comics did is they came back
and said well here's what happened after
aliens and all that kind of good stuff
the problem with this was that when
alien 3 came out as we know you know
Newt died and Hicks died and then
eventually Ripley died so the problem
was when this comic came out there were
these continuity errors you know how
could Ripley and how could Hicks and how
could Newt be alive in this comic when
they were dead in alien 3 and so what
does comic was designed to do was
basically remove them from the equation
it was designed to basically just kind
of pick them out and so they'll actually
just sort of go away and that'll be it
and so it'll be the in comic version of
them dying in alien 3 more or less I
mean it's not going to be a perfect
adaptation but it is just going to be
them kind of you know leaving the
equation but something else that I also
want to point out here is the idea of
Prometheus and alien covenant I just saw
alien covenant movies amazing I loved
alien covenant it felt like a great
blend between like alien 1 and
Prometheus it's not like it's what
Prometheus should have been in a lot of
ways I love Prometheus I thought it was
a great movie but I felt like this was
better and it was a real it was a great
return to like the alien mythos that I
know and love um but the doctor Dame's
back when alien first came out when
Ridley Scott first made that movie and
it first got released I mean it was
followed by aliens 2 which is better
than the first one what we knew or at
least the only thing we knew about the
aliens of the Xenomorphs whatever you
want to call them is that somehow or
another they were involved in what was
called the space jockey now there were
all different kinds of ideas and all
different kinds of theories were
circling around a pond and the comics
really seemed to hearken to a lot of
that but it was the idea that maybe like
this space jockeys made them or
something along those lines but their
origins were just never really fleshed
out we never really knew where they came
from with the idea of Prometheus what
they did is they came back and they said
there were these beings called the
engineers and
former fashion the engineers created the
xenomorph somewhere along lines
something that we didn't see and I'm not
going to spoil anything for for alien
covenant but with regard to what was
going on there it was basically just
like filling in gaps it was adding
information and so in a lot of ways
Prometheus and alien covenant
contradicted information that was in the
videos that we've done they contradicted
the comics of earth hide they
contradicted the comics of Nightmare
Asylum and they contradicted the comics
of this one female ward that being said
this really still kind of stands is like
an isolated story we can really just
kind of read this in isolation outside
of all the alien films and it's still
interesting it's still pretty fun it's
still kind of cool so you guys a get a
better idea of what I'm talking about as
we get through this but in the last
video in nightmares eylem we had
basically picked up with the idea that
all hell had broken loose the earth was
overrun with xenomorph and that really
just kind of seemed to be the end of
that and so in their attempts to
basically find out a way to more or less
you know purge the earth of the
Xenomorphs hicks and newt were met with
the arrival of ellen ripley and so what
this does is it basically covers what it
is that was going on because in the
comics we never knew what happened to
Ellen Ripley in the comics it was just
Hicks a newt it picked up ten years
after aliens and we never found out what
happened to Ripley what we end up
learning here is that again because of
the fact that genome Wars just kind of
running running rampant because of the
fact that you know the company was still
very much invested in learning as much
as they could about the Xenomorphs and
capturing a live specimen Ripley had
essentially gone on a mission with
another set of Marines to investigate
lv-426 but to also check out the
derelict spacecraft the space jockey
ship that was on lv-426 and that's kind
of the cool thing is because it all sort
of harkens back to the original Nostromo
an alien they picked up a beacon coming
from a derelict ship the terraforming
based in aliens was based on the same
planet where they picked up the the
beacon from the first alien so we were
all really kind of harkens back to the
same location but the fact remains here
that the idea was to capture a live
specimen to do some investigating to see
what was going on but the way the
Marines are depicted here is the same
way they were depicted exactly in aliens
they had no idea what they were getting
into at the end of the day they were
just like all it's a bug hunts but this
is that it's not a huge deal not even
you know not a huge problem or anything
along those lines it's just capturing
Xenomorphs and bringing one back but the
reason why this segment of the story is
given to us is because what this does is
it basically has
Ripley picking up the entirety of the
distress signal that was sent out by the
beacon because remember in the first
Alien movie all they did was just pick
up on it on a signal they didn't know
what it was they couldn't translate it
they couldn't figure it out they just
went down to investigate to see what was
going on what this did is it basically
told us that this beacon really seemed
to harken back to the idea that there is
a singular xenomorph somewhere out there
that's basically like the grand pooh-bah
like it is well we're going to find that
it's actually called the queen-mother
but it is like de bir alien and i hate
to use that phrase but it's like the
uber xenomorph but essentially what had
happened is somewhere along the line the
Xenomorphs had been separated from the
queen-mother and the idea was of the
Queen Mother was always calling them
back and so what Ripley had learned is
that previously it was believed that the
Xenomorphs would just just procreate
like crazy I mean they were just like
rabbits they would just show up on a
planet they would just start procreating
and they would just spread around it
would be like you know like plants to
pollinate you know for example plants
they basically reproduce by allowing
their problem to be caught in the wind
or caught by bees their carry to other
plants and they just reproduce and
that's it that seemed to be the case
with the Xenomorphs but instead what we
learn is that it's actually ordered it's
structured there is a method to the
madness and the method to this madness
is for the Queen Mother to basically
recall all of her Xenomorphs back to her
now why it is she's doing that we do not
entirely know all we know is that this
is just something that's taking place
now what we also do is they pick up with
this young girl Amy I remember in the
last video we talked about how Amy her
father and you know maybe one or two
other people were one of only several
tried several groups that had survived
on earth and they were literally just
trying to survive one day to the next
they would never go inside buildings
they would never travel around at night
they were just trying to survive the
xenomorph infestation on earth and one
of the things that they talk about here
in this video recording is basically
given to us is this idea that humans are
just kind of being whisked away by the
Queen's here or at least by the drones
to be taken to the Queens to be a cocoon
so that more Zeo Morse can be born but
what they're learning is that orders are
being given by someone just by by virtue
of how they're acting just by virtue of
the Queen's are getting a little more
brave the Queen's are you know quote
unquote
waiting on something it's basically this
idea that the earth is being prepped for
the arrival of a particular thing and
again it really seems to be like all
this is you know kind of hitting back to
the idea of the Queen
mother and so what ends up happening
here is Ripley along with Hicks and Newt
having figured out everything that's
going on realizing that there is
essentially this Queen Mother launched
an attempt to get back to the to the
xenomorph home planet now the reason why
is because according to Ripley if they
get back to the xenomorph home planet
they can capture the Queen Mother
because the Queen Mother is presumably
the source of xenomorph see the origin
points the place from which they all
came they can take the Queen Mother
back to earth they can drop her off in a
location and then in turn they can just
destroy the Queen Mother and all the
drones and Queens that will gather
around here and then just completely go
through and effectively save the earth
and so that's really the motivation here
that's really the desire here now the
way that Ripley is doing this is
actually pretty smart
essentially what she's done is she has
gone through and she's created what
looks like xenomorph drones and these
are all held in some sort of a stasis
base and so the idea is that the Queen
Mother will see these drones believe
they're her children and then run to
them in order to basically bond with
them and then recall them back you know
take them back with her to her home base
so to speak in that moment
Ripley will capture the Queen Mother and
then drag her back to earth so it's
actually a pretty solid plan and it
actually works out or at least it seems
it would work out pretty well but of
course as we know this is an alien comic
and things never work out that well
now the crazy thing about this is this
is when we get into the nature of how it
is the Queen Mother functions and what
it is that she does remember the
xenomorph homeworld is very clandestine
I mean we really don't get a whole lot
in terms of like the entire makeup of
the planet what it's like so on and so
forth but it does appear to have
effectively been terraformed and so
whenever it is that you are going
through and you are watching like aliens
or you are watching alien and they would
have those weird structures that would
be created by xenomorph that's the
entire planet the basic fundamental I
guess the genealogy or the basic general
core of the planet has been changed the
entire planets just one giant xenomorph
locale one kind of you know one giant
genome or planet and so because of that
this Queen Mother at least you know as
they end up finding out here this Queen
Mother is not surrounded by just your
traditional xenomorph drones not at all
they are these very specialized and
massive drones I mean they are huge in
size something almost equivalent to the
size of a queen maybe a little bit
smaller but they are huge in terms of
their stature
point basically winds up happening is
Ripley along with a handful of people
travel out onto the onto the xenomorph
homeworld and power loaders and these
drones are about the size of the power
loaders not only that they are colossal
and strength they're literally just
tearing the power loaders you know limb
from limb now this is an indication of
how strong these things are because
remember when Ripley fought a queen and
the aliens movie the power loader was
equivalent and strength more or less you
know it was hydraulics to meet physical
strength Ripley was able to basically
hold off the Queen and then eventually
kind of jettison her into space and that
was really it the fact that these you
know massive drone aliens are basically
ripping off the limbs of these machines
indicates just how strong they are now
of course what we also end up having is
is basically this royal jelly that
basically exists around there now as we
talked about in our video where we had
run over all these different types of
xenomorph this royal jelly serves the
purpose of creating a new Queen Mother
should the existing Queen Mother die and
so the implication here is that there is
only ever one Queen Mother at a time
it's like a beehive there's only ever
one queen bee at a time if that Queen
dies another will take its place or
another beehive may come in there kill
that existing Queen run all the other
bees out and then take over the hive but
whatever the case may be there's only
ever one Queen in any beehive at any
particular point in time and that Queen
basically kind of runs through
everything so it's almost like this
continued expansion of the xenomorph
hierarchy in the sense that you have a
Queen Mother and then you know kind of
skipping over a few things here and
there you've got a queen and then you've
got drones and so because of this Ellen
Ripley officially calls out this Queen
Mother now in truth what's happening in
this story kind of stretches the limits
of credulity to a degree and the reason
why is because of the fact that we've
seen drones just tear human beings limb
from limb
yet somehow a lot of these guys are able
to stand between her I just stand
against these massively oversized drones
and still hold their own but the fact
remains this Queen Mother is wildly
intelligent in terms of what is capable
of what it basically does is it recalls
essentially thousands and thousands of
these alien drones to it in order to
both overrun Ellen Ripley and her forces
killed him and then essentially take
over the ship now what did we do after
that we don't know because as far as I'm
aware Xenomorphs don't know how to fly
ships and if they did it'd be terrifying
his health but this is where I say
things begin to stretch a little bit of
credulity is because we have new
and we have Hicks and a couple of these
soldiers taking on these thousands of
drones with pulse rifles and holding
their own it really seems to be more of
like a circumstance of convenience than
anything else just because of the fact
that we've seen stories where a group of
Marines are overrun by like 50 drones
and they're just totally destroyed you
know there's no hope for those Marines
to survive yet you know five of them are
able to hold their own against thousands
of them but ultimately this really seems
to hit back to the idea of how the
drones function in relation to the
queen-mother innocence that were Ellen
Ripley basically kind of go to the Queen
Mother into a rage the Queen whether
attacks er goes to bite the arm and then
Ripley kind of drags the Queen Mother
back into the ship and it's stasis pod
the idea seems to be here set drones
will not know how to function without
the Queen Mother you know it would be
like for example if you were to take and
take a queen out of a bee Hut you know
there would be a state of panic well
what do we do who gives us our orders
you know where we go we we have no idea
who's supposed to be doing what and
where it would cause all different kinds
of problems and so because of that with
the Queen Mother basically taking a
being taken captive the Xenomorphs are
running on whatever orders they have
left which is just attack you know these
guys who are here they make their escape
they get back onto the ship and they
take off back to earth a during which
time they blow up you know one of the
vehicles they left behind killing all
these drones and then that's basically
it and so making their way back to earth
again the ultimate goal here is to bring
the Xena Aubrey Nia Queen mother back on
earth and drop her off now here's the
genius of the plan there's a genius of
this idea if they were to grab the Queen
Mother and they were to drop her off on
earth and they were just then blow it up
they would kill the Queen Mother and
that would be yet the question would
have to be asked if the Queen Mother is
killed regardless of where she is in the
universe then when is a new Queen Mother
going to crop up what steps are taken in
order to lead to the birth of a new
Queen Mother now it probably wouldn't
happen immediately it would probably
take time but a new Queen Mother would
emerge whether it's several generations
down the line or whether it's an
immediate process a queen just kind of
starts molting and and turns into a
queen mother regardless another one
would take that Queen mother's place and
so the goal is to basically grab the
Queen Mother and drop her off on earth
and then let it sit there for about six
months and the reason why is because
what would happen is all these drones
from across the world would begin
gathering into a singular location after
which they can just stockpile nukes and
then just drop a ton of them onto the
Queen Mother and although xenomorphs and
why
them all out now in truth it would make
the earth virtually uninhabitable for
probably a thousand years to be honest
because of the nuclear radiation or the
the nuclear winter and all that kind of
stuff but small price to pay to make the
earth habitable again so because of that
the cool thing about this is that for
the character of Newt she's still stuck
in the idea that this little girl Amy
needs to be saved now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
amy is - Newt what Newt was - Ripley
remember in the aliens movie uh Ripley
had basically found Newt and Rick Lee
had essentially outlived her daughter
you know at the end of aliens she was
just kind of in cryostasis floating in
space for forty five years or something
like that when they thought her out and
woke her up they told her hey look your
daughters like 60 something years old
you know with regards to nuke he was
like you know a surrogate daughter for
Ellen Ripley it was like you know Ellen
Ripley basically being able to take care
of her daughter when she wasn't while
she was floating out in space for the
character of Newt
this little girl Amy and her father who
were on this planet trying to survive
day by day is like a girl that she can
save for a nude it's like if she says
aiming then she's able to do at least
something that matters she's able to
save someone from its horrendous
experience not to mention that with the
entirety of this you know more
copulation expected to be nuked Amy
would have no chance of surviving anyway
and so what actually is up happening
here is new works directly against Ellen
Ripley she actually sabotages the
mission to a degree innocence the wall
she doesn't like detonate the ship early
or anything along those lines
she actually grabs the shuttle and takes
off down to earth now at this point it's
really just Ripley saying okay look we
gotta postpone things just because of
the fact that I'm not going to let new
dye me is just not going to be that way
and it makes sense because Newt is a
daughter to Ripley in a lot of different
ways they've been through a lot together
you know Newt was saved by Ripley it
makes sense that Ripley would go after
her and try to save her life but what
ultimately ends up happening here is
Ripley where she considers knew to be a
fool where she considers her to kind of
be stupid for the for what it is that
she's doing we ultimately end up
learning that the reason why is of
course newts trying to save this little
girl Amy and it changes the way Ripley
views what it is that Newt is doing it
actually allows her to sympathise with
Newt to a degree and so because of this
with the Queen Mother also being dropped
off and engineering her escape
Ripley just kind of shoots the Queen
Mother up you know or at least tried to
hold her off as best she can but one of
the things established here is that the
Queen Mother can communicate with drones
no matter where she is and all drones
will listen it's like a built-in thing
you know it's the million
currently understand as soon as the
Queen Mother arrives Queens listen to
the Queen Mother groans listen to the
Queen Mother everybody follows her
command no questions asked it was very
animal instinct in that capacity and
that's what makes it kind of cool like
you know the Queen Mother shows up and
all the drones just immediately start
following her orders all the Queen's
immediately start following her orders
no questions asked and that's really all
there is to it and so of course what
this does is it leads to a direct
conflict again you know with Ripley and
with nude and all these different
xenomorph
and this is when things again begin to
kind of stretch the limits of credulity
because now it's somehow Ellen Ripley
and Hicks really kind of standing
against just like these thousands of
drones and this Queen Mother but in the
end it's really more of just an attempt
to get out with their lives at this
point it's not even really about like
trying to eradicate what's left of the
infestation it's just let's get out of
here and let's call it a day and that's
exactly what happens I mean they get in
a little escape hop you know they
jettison out of the place they get back
to their ship and they head over they
head towards Gateway station now of
course again gateway station is
basically just a space station that sits
outside of the earth and it's filled
with what's left of humanity those
individuals who were lucky enough to
escape the earth during the initial
stages of the xenomorph infestation and
so again this really kind of begins to
wrap up this trilogy and it leaves a lot
of things open-ended just because the
fact that this wasn't enough time to
wrap it all up instead what we end up
finding out here at least from what Newt
tells us and again this has left a
little bit ambiguous in terms of how it
is she knows it she really just kind of
insinuates the idea that it came by way
of dreams but what we're basically told
here is that all of this had been
basically planned out by a space jockey
that somewhere along the line a space
jockey had survived or a space jockey
had witnessed everything that was going
on and it sent this entire thing in
motion now the space jockey did not set
like the the colonization of Earth by
the xenomorph
in motion it didn't have anything
involved in that but the idea of the
space jockey was to basically terraform
the earth we don't know why we just know
that was its motivation and so what
ended up happening is through you know
whether it was it seemed to be you know
telepathic in some form or fashion but
regardless the space jockey was the
reason why Ellen Ripley and these
Marines had traveled back to lv-426 and
stumbled across the signal that was that
was a picked up by this Nostromo
deciphered the entirety of the signal
and learned about the Queen Mother
knowing that once Ellen Ripley had the
location of the Queen Mother that she
would capture it and all the events this
counter
would take place assume what would
happen is if Ellen Ripley what was left
of humanity what effectively rid the
earth of the alien infestation for the
space jockey who in turn would go back
and just terraforming earth just
effectively take over the entirety of
the planet because at this point there's
really no one left alive there really
are no survivors on earth at least not
that I'm aware of um there is a one shot
that follows this they're basically
deals with like what happens when the
space jockey shows up on earth but it's
not very good
and even then it basically contradicts
everything going on in the realm of
continuity I mean it's it's I mean we
might cover it you know just for the
sake of having it but it contradicts a
lot of information that's here you know
for example like the the ship actually
lands on earth so on and so forth but
for the most part virtually everybody
every single person every single human
being on earth is gone if they didn't
escape you know they're on Gateway
station but everybody who stayed on
earth is dead the fact remains here that
this really kind of wraps things up
because again this story was designed
for the purpose of essentially just
removing Hicks and nude and Ripley from
the alien comics in order to more or
less fall in line with the idea that
they're gone in the in the alien films
at least you know roughly as a human as
well as a Hicks and Newt and so what is
what happening is once they basically
escape the earth they travel to Gateway
station presumably kind of live out
their lives there that seems to be the
implication and that's really it I mean
we never really see or hear from them
again that's really all there is to it
their characters kind of gone from the
equation but following this we start
getting into things like alien genocide
and they're really just kind of like
standalone stories for the most part as
far as I'm aware there really isn't a
whole lot of like continuity it's just
things like like alien genocide for
example is like busy no more civil war
or we learned that there are different
like tied by two main types of
xenomorphs the red and the black ones
and they just fight amongst themselves
we just learn you know different
different things like alien harvest
colonial Marines we just get a lot of
these really really cool standalone
stories with regards to the alien
landscape but anyway guys if you are new
here to come let's explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]